nous avons perdu l'un des meilleurs d'entre nous ce
matin Gord était mon ami bien Gord était
les amis de tout le monde qui nous étions notre copain
Gord qui aimait ce pays avec
tout ce qu'il avait et pas seulement aimé d'
une manière nébuleuse oh j'aime le Canada il aimait
chaque caché  coin de chaque histoire chaque
aspect de ce pays qu'il a
célébré toute sa vie et il voulait
l'améliorer il savait aussi grand que nous
étions que nous devions être meilleurs que nous ne le sommes
et c'est pourquoi ses dernières années ont été
consacrées à Chaney est allé Jack et  pour
diriger la conciliation, c'est quelque chose
dont j'ai certainement puisé l'inspiration
et la force et nous sommes nous sommes moins en
tant que pays sans Gord ici et
cela arrivait mais nous espérions que ce n'était pas le cas
j'allais m'en sortir mais
je  'ai connu que ça fait mal